blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman so unfortunately uh we are going
very much the wrong direction in a lot
of ways in this country when it comes to
just common decency and quite frankly
law and order now i know that law and
order is typically a phrase weaponized
by the right against the left but
we now have
even fox news host tucker carlson
talking about fake vaccination cards a
card
that looks like a real cdc card saying
you've been vaccinated against covid but
it's fake tucker carlson referring to
these cards as and those who get them as
desperate acts
by good law abiding people now it's
against the law so how do you call
something that's against the law
law abiding it's weird we're going to
look at the clip in a moment daily beast
writing about it
tucker carlson advocates for the
unvaccinated to get fake vaccine cards
quote act of desperation
taking his criticism of vaccine mandates
to a whole new level
tucker seemingly advocated for
unvaccinated people to obtain fake
vaccination cards claiming it's not a
serious crime
but instead an act of desperation for
law-abiding americans who have been
forced into a corner
earlier this week manhattan d.a cyrus
vance jr announced 15 people are now
facing charges over a conspiracy to
forge
covet 19 vaccine cards and fraudulently
enter
uh people into new york's vaccination
database 13 of the people charged for
buying the bogus cards are quote
believed to work in front line in
essential employee settings including
hospitals and nursing homes
the scheme involved a forger who
allegedly advertised the sale of fake
cards on her instagram account for 200
bucks apiece
for another 250 a long island nurse
would then allegedly enter the buyer's
name into the new york state
immunization information system
according to vance's office roughly 250
of these cards were sold
in an effort to avoid vaccination
mandates the article explains that
carlson has been a loud vaccine skeptic
has railed against mandates
said all sorts of stuff so let's go to
the video
here is tucker carlson take a listen
so in good conscience
they've risked their careers to preserve
their right to bodily autonomy and now
they're in jail for that so understand
that
when you
um offer a fake vaccine card to someone
or
you falsely enter someone into a state's
vaccination database tucker is saying
these are almost heroic people
taking a risk to preserve bodily
autonomy
these are crimes this is fraud that's
what it is and they claim to be about
law and order about the listen this is
the law
now these arrests will be used to
justify digital health passports for the
entire american population that is true
save this tape
in fact cyrus vance has already enlisted
big tech to help root out the
disobedient in new york quote we need
companies like facebook to take action
to prevent the fraud happening on their
platform now even the use of the term
disobedient is just a loaded term
because what we're talking about when
people lie about vaccination status is
number one it's a crime if it's a fake
cdc card you're using a federal agent
you're fraudulently using a federal
agency sealed as a crime um but the use
of the term disobedient is obviously
cynical and tongue-in-cheek and it's
meant to say these are people who won't
be bullied by the man it said making
selling and purchasing forged
vaccination cards are serious crimes
with serious public safety they're
certainly crimes there's no doubt about
that sequences
end quote except that's a lie
buying a fake vaccination card is not a
quote serious crime it's not even close
to a serious crime
buying a fake vaccination card is an act
of desperation
by decent law-abiding americans who have
been forced into a corner by tyrants now
quite literally
when you commit a crime you're not law
abiding these are the people who say
they hold the principle of law and order
above everything and he's essentially
saying these are decent law abiding
law breakers they are desperate and good
people
you know what's a serious crime
forcing americans to take drugs they
don't need or want that's a very serious
crime now of course that is a complete
mix-up here that uh and and that is not
actually what is taking place
employers can say
if you want to work here
then you must be vaccinated if you want
to shop here the government can say our
employees can do the same there is even
the legal argument based on the 90 1905
case jacobson v massachusetts that the
government could mandate vaccinations
more generally but that's not actually
what has taken place and let's hope in
the end someone is punished for it
severely
yeah so tucker's saying that it's the
people
uh
requiring vaccines that are the people
that should be punishing punished so
buying fake vaccine cards violates the
law that by definition means you are not
law abiding making and selling fake
vaccine cards violates the law that by
definition means you are not law abiding
now tucker has talked about this before
about people who get fake papers to go
someplace that they wouldn't otherwise
be allowed
but he wasn't calling them law abiding
then
he was sort of using more muted language
now he's just going and saying it it's
it's the trump thing of what you're
seeing with your own eyes you can't or
shouldn't believe
these are law abiding but they're
committing a crime they're breaking a
law here's the law that they are
breaking but these are decent
law-abiding people this is really scary
stuff and of course it's only going to
encourage more of it now with joe
biden's federal employee vaccine
requirement i can only imagine that
these people are going to go absolutely
crazy
this feels like yet another one of those
stories and it is another one it's not
the same one from before it's a
different story
there is now a volusia county florida
councilman
who has been ridiculing dr fauci
who is now hospitalized with very
serious covid
this is fred lowry okay
volusia county councilman fred lowry is
hospitalized with covid
quote he is in the hospital wrestling
with covid19
he's pretty darn sick councilwoman billy
wheeler added in the afternoon
wheeler told the news journal that lowry
was hospitalized monday after being
treated with monoclonal antibodies last
friday quote he has been sick for around
two weeks and got the antibody treatment
last friday went to the emergency room
late last night
brower said lowry had double pneumonia
but added doctors were hopeful he'd come
home thursday
he had pneumonia a couple years ago his
lungs are already pretty beat
lowry a 67-year-old republican is midway
through his second four-year term he
attracted controversy this summer for
promoting conspiracy theories including
some about the coronavirus pandemic in a
sermon at deltona lakes baptist church
politics and religion very intertwined
in volusia county
we did not have a pandemic folks we were
loud lied to lowry said on may 30th
he referred to dr fauci
as dr falci
i did not mispronounce that he said
that's the way i wanted to say it he
labeled fauci a liar and a pervert
he also took issue with by the way
pervert
is that even being alleged he also took
issue with media coverage of the covid
treatment hydroxychloroquine it's funny
to call it a covet treatment because
what we figured out is it's not actually
a cova treatment
um and media coverage of the theory that
coronavirus originated in a wuhan lab
larry missed last week's special meeting
he last attended a meeting on august
17th whoop and we just lost the article
it's back
um lowry last preached in a sermon live
streamed august 29
pastor bill hicks gave the sermon sunday
acknowledging lowry and many other
church-goers were absent then turning to
the subject of the pandemic some of you
may have been told mass are mandatory
they are not we're trying to take
precautions as best as possible but that
was misinformation
you know this is further proof that not
believing in something doesn't mean it
doesn't have an effect on you you cannot
believe in gravity and you will still be
bound by the effects of gravity
uh on earth period
and uh this sort of reminds me a little
bit actually of a this is a nice
historical note this reminds me of the
story of ignaz semelweis
semel weiss was a hungarian doctor
and he was kind of like an early pioneer
of antiseptic procedures on the basis of
starting to understand the germ theory
there's these invisible things that we
can get rid of with antiseptic practices
and and cleaning and lots of people at
the time just slammed him they couldn't
accept at the time when someone weiss
would say
washing hygiene these things will save
lives in medical settings a lot of
people didn't want to accept that at the
time and it turns out whether you
believed semel weiss or not
you were bound by the reality that he
was right about germs if you were going
from patient to patient without washing
hands or sanitizing or whatever didn't
matter if you believed in it or not it
was going to have an effect on the
patients and it's sort of a similar
situation with covid and it's similar
with simply just the way gravity works
so i take no pleasure in this but yet
another kova denier who has been
hospitalized with kovid was in theory
going to be released yesterday we don't
know if he was we'll follow up if we get
more information we have a fantastic
program for you today
let me know what you would like covered
next week by sending me a tweet at d
pacman you're following me on twitter
right we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show is
funded mostly by viewers and listeners
who sign up at join
joinpackman.com
you get access to the daily bonus show
as a member as well as a commercial free
audio feed of the show
a commercial free video feed of the show
and so many other things sign up at
joinpackman.com
let's
start today
with brian
from gainesville floor uh not
gainesville florida gainesville georgia
brian from gainesville you're on the air
hey david glad you're doing well and yes
that's that's georgia uh not florida
thank you uh
yeah so i was uh i was the caller who
called in about the uh triage question
about some month or so ago okay
um
so
i'm really disturbed by the amount of
anti-vaxx propaganda coming particularly
from nurses
and i'm just curious what do you
what do you think we should do as a
society about that i mean i've said
before
the best protection against
disinformation is an educated critically
thinking population
i don't think that going after nurses
and again i i agree with you there's a
disturbingly high amount of
disinformation coming from nurses
anecdotally i still think
nurses are not nearly the primary
vectors of disinformation but but it is
particularly concerning because nurses
are someone that many people might say
well it's a medical professional i
should be i should be able to trust what
they say we actually have an email i'm
gonna i'm gonna show a little bit later
on in today's show
uh a couple emails actually about this
um
i think that we really have to just
educate people
and teach people how to evaluate whether
something they're being told makes sense
and unfortunately you can't do this in
six months in the middle of a pandemic
it starts much earlier so it's a real
conundrum
i completely agree
yeah do you have any ideas
uh i
to to be honest no i don't i don't have
any specific ideas that that uh that
come to mind uh
you know i hesitate to say that you know
if you're a nurse and you
say something uh
that is uh that's you know that that is
false i hesitate to say that you should
just lose your job
um that seems you know that seems like
it might be might be kind of draconian
depending on the the context i mean
here's one thing i think is important to
keep in mind very often people will say
the best way to fight bad ideas is with
good ideas but there's actually a
problem with that
because
fear uncertainty doubt catastrophic
predictions
uh are much more
salacious and appeal to people much more
right negative headlines do better than
positive headlines you're actually at a
structural disadvantage just by
countering
wrong information about the vaccine
with correct information because there's
something about the wrong information
this idea of this is what they don't
want you to know
that makes it stickier and so we
actually need something more than just
good information i don't know what that
something is
yeah and there's so much there's so much
misinformation out there that it just
takes so long to
to go through everything point by point
it's kind of kind of like how in
arguments people gish gallup that's kind
of kind of how how i see that very much
so it's so much of it out there
well we'll keep
fighting
i agree we should all right thank you so
much for the call
thank you david all right
let's keep chatting with people because
we we really have uh
so many different people here who want
to check in let's go next to next to
zach from toronto canada zac you're on
the air
hey david uh can you hear me i can hear
you your discord is blinging so please
mute that or maybe we can just come back
to you later
okay um i have it on do not disturb so
it shouldn't mute so it shouldn't be
anymore good beautiful um
i just wanted to say that i'm a really
big fan of the show thank you
um
and i wanted to ask
do you like what do you see a line with
um
kind of like what the republicans are
saying right now like i look at like
madison hawthorne saying like
there will be bloodshed and like
um
marjorie taylor green
uh
influencing people to like shoot
vaccinated people do you see a line with
the republican party like do you see
uh like do you mean do i see a line they
won't cross
yeah yeah that's what i meant not really
no i mean i think i think the here's the
thing the line they won't there's no
moral line that they won't cross
the line they won't cross is over into
what they think will be bad for them
electorally or will be bad for their
fundraising but morally i see no line
that they're unwilling to cross no
okay and um
do you have any feelings of how that
will look in
say
2022 or 2024
if like marjorie taylor green and lauren
bober continue getting the support
they have right now
so i'm going to let you go because the
discord won't stop blinging i'll answer
the question off air um
2022 is going to look like now so my my
belief is
these trumpian radicals
are going to go into 22 the way that
they they've been this year
if it wins them re-election in 22
they will be emboldened and trump will
almost certainly run in 24.
if they get defeated with this nonsense
in 22
they will have to rethink it and so i
think the question is
once we the issue is once we know how 22
goes for them then we'll be able to say
if and how they'll modify their approach
but morally i'm not aware of any line
that these people are unwilling to cross
let's continue speaking to folks via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord
let's go next to
jonah from st louis jonah you're on the
air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
hey david yeah so
i was
watching a previous episode and you were
making comment about
uh how
more republicans don't come out against
trump
um you know i think you were referring
to paul ryan at the time
and your reason was that paul ryan was
running for office he wouldn't have the
courage to do so
um but i think you know we have a couple
of really good examples of
of politicians doing that in this chain
and um
and liz cheney and adam kinzinger
yes there's no question so i don't
remember if i said he he wouldn't i mean
i i definitely said he doesn't have to
worry because he's not running i i'm not
saying he definitely wouldn't if he were
running for something but it's just he's
not running for anything right now and
right now he's free to say whatever but
you're right i mean kenzinger
mitt romney there are liz cheney there
are people it's it's not even always
that they're coming out against trump
they're just sort of telling some truth
that the trumpists are unwilling to hear
like joe biden really won but i think
it's certainly easier when you're not
running for anything to just speak your
mind
yeah i totally agree with that i guess
my point is that um i think in another
episode um you know you were you were
sort of downplaying
um what cheney and kinzinger were doing
you know and and you know i guess uh
highlighting what
what their downsides are more than than
what you know what they're currently
doing to speak up against
you know trumpism yeah um and you know
i'm wondering if that's a missed
opportunity to kind of make better
examples of what's going on there
and then uh you know making it a safer
place right for for people like them to
do that no but here's the thing you have
to remember
the
liz cheney
told the truth that joe biden really won
liz cheney still voted with trump's
position 90 of the time so it's not that
i was downplaying the point was
this party has become so perverted that
just stating who won the election is
considered dissent and that's crazy but
at the end of the day these are not my
friends as a progressive because they
still agree with trump on just about
everything it wasn't about down playing
or up playing it was just about
explaining on policy these are not
people i agree with
yeah yeah no i get that i guess it's uh
i guess the little wind strategy right
take what you can get and then they
could you know just climb it the the
problem is
how much are we going to give them an
attaboy just for acknowledging who won
the election like yes compared to many
of their cohorts they're they're doing
something that's different but it
shouldn't be something you get a it's
sort of like when parents use food as a
reward and they're like you know if you
eat your veggies then we'll give you a
pound of ice cream and it's like no no
like you just you get veggies are part
of the meal you should you you don't
want to use it as a you don't want to
start using as a reward something that
should just be hey we eat a balanced
diet in this house and it's sort of the
same idea like how much are we going to
really praise them just for telling us
who won the election uh i get why but
let's not go overboard
yeah that makes sense i appreciate it my
pleasure yeah thanks for calling in
there's jonah from st louis
let's go next to
charlie from bayfield colorado now
charlie is bayfield
one of the blue parts of colorado or one
of the red parts
extremely red okay gotcha all right
we'll go ahead
hey man so
i had a had a little commentary i wanted
to make
um
if you would play along for a second
okay
can you
spell the
word are can you say the word s-a-u-s-e
s-a-u-s-e
[Music]
or c-e my bad c-e oh that's uh sauce
right
okay what about the word
a-u-r-a
that is aura
aura okay interesting
i'm just i'm just kind of weirded out
about how you always mispronounce vosh's
name after he told you what it is
oh it's just a joke it's just an ongoing
joke that's all it is
i think he says pac-man as well or
something like that it's just a joke
is it not pac-man it's pac-man not
pac-man
oh okay yeah
oh funny so just a little back and forth
between you guys yeah yeah it's just a
joke
oh hey i was just i was so i was i was
upset because i was just i was hoping it
wasn't some giga cringe on your part so
no no no that we have a strict no giga
cringe policy on this show
okay okay okay i believe it i believe
that well hey which is why i'm gonna
have to which is why i'm gonna have to
let you go
[Laughter]
okay and charlie bailed all right wow uh
clip it that's quite quite a phone call
okay let's continue here um let's go
next to miles from bay city michigan
hello mr backman can you hear me just
barely miles i'm going to crank you up
as loud as i can
about now sir it's marginally better
uh
one and more comment on observations
i've been seeing you know since i've
been
working back in the office
i mean i've been kind of appalled by the
amount of people that are hanging flags
or having decorations that are
you know having profanities like f-bomb
joe biden and it's just like
really
i know it's like very it's like a
continued coarsening of the discourse i
saw a video earlier today
of a guy just walking through a retail
store with an f biden flag
and it's less about like i don't care
you know i don't care about the
profanity
but
these are these are what i call asbs
these are attention seeking behaviors
and very often there's like something
going on emotionally for the people that
do it because f biden
you know this is not i feel really
strongly about abortion and i'm against
it right i would disagree with you but
at least it's sort of like substantive
at least ostensibly
but
f biden it's just an attention seeking
behavior and
i almost sometimes wonder whether it's
better not to give it any attention not
to even acknowledge it
i mean i can definitely understand that
aspect but
i don't know maybe it's just like
growing up as a kid you know i don't
recall seeing anything of this sort to
where it's just like i grew up in a
christian household you know even saying
you know any even lesser swear word was
very punishable so the fact that you
know there are kids out there today that
kind of see this stuff and i don't know
if kids are like me when i was growing
up i'd see something and i'd repeat it
so it's just a matter of oh great
yeah i mean i don't have i don't have
that hang up like i don't really worry
about kids seeing profanity you know in
many countries tv has profanity and it's
just like no big deal so for me it's
less about that it's just that the
discourse is getting stupider and
stupider and
people don't understand the difference
between what kind of a statement is a
factual statement and what kind of a
statement is a statement of opinion
and we're really just losing our ability
to even disagree
because
people misunderstand what it even means
to have an opinion disagreement versus
to be unable to establish the facts of
something so for me it's more of like a
structural problem
ah very understandable yeah
well i appreciate your time so but let
me ask you so when you see the f biden
flags that co-workers have do you do you
acknowledge it or mention it in any way
or just ignore it
uh no thankfully none of my co-workers
do it's just i got quite a commute to
the office so oh it's more
it's more along the lines of you know as
i'm going to work and passing through i
gotcha
stuff like that
and
it's
to me it's still just a little eyebrow
raising again it's just the amount of
profanities and it's just like come on
think of
i don't know
children thing is an important part it
sounds like
exactly gotcha i'm
not
it's not it's not a paid job it's part
of a hobby but i i help teach martial
arts and you know i i have a you know
soft spot for kids you know i want to
make sure i teach them good things and
stuff like that outside of martial arts
so
at that point when i see that stuff i'm
like i guess they don't care about kids
seeing that kind of stuff i mean i've
seen one where it's the same kind of fun
except it says impeach bite and i'm like
thank you at least you have the decency
to not use profanities
at least that's ostensibly a political
statement yeah all right my friend well
i appreciate the perspective thank you
all right thank you sir all right let's
take a quick pause if you're holding on
to talk to me and you continue to want
to talk to me if you've not been
dissuaded yet just hang on because we're
going right back to the phones
momentarily
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
we're continuing to speak to people in
the audience you really make the show
what it is if it weren't for you i would
just be a guy in a room with a
microphone talking to nobody so it
you're making this situation much less
sad that you're there
let's talk next to oh i don't know let's
go to mark from dublin now is this
dublin ireland of or one of the many
dublins in the united states
this is dublin ireland all right well
hello welcome welcome
hi um
so
i was wondering um
what your thoughts
are on the
trump's immigration policy inc compared
to obama's immigration policy
i think you and i would both agree that
whilst trump is a lot worse than
obama and biden
neither are as progressive as we would
like and
i believe that obama deported more
people than any previous president
so
how do you think we can critique
trump's immigration policy
and retaining the big picture of
systemic issues with the american
immigration policy well i think the
systemic issue is that the the there's a
couple of systemic issues and neither
trump nor obama
solved them and we could argue about to
what degree did they make them worse or
do nothing about it or or fix them a
little
one is
the overwhelming focus on the
individuals who are
in the united states illegally
versus cracking down on the companies
that continue to hire them cracking down
on the companies that continue to hire
them if you really wanna like aside from
a guest worker program
whether it should be illegal to just
come like whatever your views are
the the lack of crackdown on the
companies doing the hiring continues to
be one of the biggest aggravating
factors in the situation remaining what
it is obama didn't fix that and trump
didn't fix that i think trump showed
even less interest than obama did in
dealing with that so that's one thing i
think that's a fair critique number two
um
you know daca
is a massive issue some kind of
permanent solution to daca
seems to be in the top three issues when
it comes to immigration
and that continues to be an issue and we
can continue to criticize for the lack
of a permanent solution there so i agree
with you that president obama left much
to be desired when it when it comes to
immigration
trump really scaled up
one of the most outwardly
despicable aspects which were you know
the family separations and the so-called
kids in cages and i know the counter is
that that also existed under obama i
wouldn't deny that but scaling that up
in conjunction with this very
xenophobically motivated uh uh
i call it for shorthand a majority
muslim country ban i think there's
certainly more criticism of trump than
of obama although there's plenty to
criticize of both
okay fair um what are some specific
policies under trump that you think um
um made him particularly bad um just the
scaling up or there are additional
policies well so again a lot of what
trump did wrongly on immigration
is
not just the scaling up
of the um separations and kids in cages
it was also using the pandemic to very
cynically be able to do more deportation
under the guise of public health while
clearly not actually caring about it
using the doc the lack of daca
resolution
um as a sort of uh
stick with which to bully people i mean
it he didn't pass that much policy other
than the majority muslim country ban it
was sort of the totality of his rhetoric
his cynical use of the pandemic to
continue a xenophobic immigration policy
you know it's all these things together
it's less about here's the laws he
signed the bills he signed okay
okay okay so it's also how he enforced
the laws that we're taking place indeed
okay
okay um yeah well thanks for taking my
call um appreciate speaking with you
again my pleasure thank you so much for
calling in
let's go
next to
scipio in california scipio you're next
hey david uh do i sound okay you sound
great
okay cool uh so i'm from california so
i've been following the california
recall election yes so i wanted to ask
you a couple things sure how do you
think the california recall is going to
go like who do you think is going to
come out on top and if the worst case
scenario
happens where
larry elder gets the win how do you
think that would go
so i am increasingly confident
that
when it was 50 50 in terms of keep or or
remove gavin newsom
not enough people were really paying
attention yet and over the last 10 days
as many shows including ours have been
talking more and more about the recall
we've seen gavin newsom pull to almost
like a 10 point lead for keeping him
rather than removing him
so i'm cautiously optimistic that gavin
newsom is going to stay now
if he doesn't and larry elder becomes
the governor of california
i think it would be so
horrifying
that i'm not even ready to to make any
predictions as to what would happen i i
think it would be untold
orders of magnitude disaster and i'm
sort of trying not to even take it that
seriously because it would be so
horrible and i'm optimistic that gavin
newsom will stay
yeah i i feel the same way and my family
most of my family works in medicine so
we're all
very concerned about the possibility of
a larry elder win
just for what that would mean for masks
and vaccines in the state alone um it
would be a nightmare now are you are you
also are you as sort of cautiously
optimistic as i am that newsom will will
prevail
yeah uh it was either early this morning
late yesterday i looked at the polling
data again for the first time in a bit
and i was
i breathed a sigh of relief but i'm
i'm hesitant to be that optimistic
because i don't know what's gonna happen
in the next week we have left of this
thing i understand and by the way my i'm
hoping to cover the results live on
tuesday will we even get live results on
tuesday or are they not going to be
known until later in the week
uh i'm i'm not sure okay uh from what i
understand we'll know tuesday but i
don't know if something else is going on
okay all right yeah i mean i'll plan to
cover some of it anyway and then if we
don't know exactly we don't know but
that sounds good
yeah great thanks for taking my call man
my pleasure thank you for the call let's
hope for the best there in uh in
california it could get very ugly very
very ugly and that would be
it's
i i don't even want to think about it i
don't even want to think about it
let's try bart from california it's been
a while since we've heard from bart
what's going on
bart from california you're on the air
please unmute you'll be able to chat
with me
and bart from california last chance
i'm here david can you hear me okay
now i can sort of hear you yeah
yeah sorry about that i followed it i
was trying to figure out the new
i'm not i need to learn more about the
discord
okay i really have two questions for you
and thoughts
um one is is there is there any way to
get the message this progressive message
that you that you're you know that
you're also supporting obviously
to the to the other side so to speak in
other words there's a lot of there's a
lot of echo chamber going on obviously
in the red states and so on
how can we combat that number one
because i think that's
part of it is there's just no other
way to get to these people and it seems
like
um and two would you be willing to do
something along those lines to help get
the message out
sorry to get to get what message out
oh uh to get your message out to you
know because right now it seems like a
lot of times we're basically in an echo
chamber of our own where we're listening
to our aggressive message and all that
but i'm just trying to think of ways to
help get the message to uh to
republicans and those people that have
basically a fox news echo chamber so i'm
just trying to figure out ways we can
help them
you know maybe some of them anyway yeah
i mean this is a much bigger issue than
you know anything i can do obviously
anytime i you know when trump is call in
i talk to them and we have a lot of
right wingers who are who are in our
audience and
but but these are bigger issues about
algorithms on social media and
confirmation bias these are really big
things that are sort of bigger than any
one show
right
anything i can do i would be glad to do
of course you know but but it just this
is like just a such a massive issue
i know it's is there any possibility of
having to show on uh fox news i know it
sounds funny but commercials or any kind
of thing like that is that is there
anything that we can do or is it all
controlled by fox and they'll say just
no that's interesting you're saying
could we get could we buy a commercial
for the david pakman show on fox news
correct that is correct that's
interesting that's an interesting idea i
mean listen i'm more than willing to
look into that we'd probably have to
crowdfund for i don't know what it would
cost mike lindell would know right he's
run commercials on there
i think if we if we put a commercial for
the david pakman show on fox news it
would be
fascinating let let's if anybody in the
audience wants to help look into that i
would that would be great
yeah please add my name to the to the
people supporting it however i can help
okay very good yeah we'll look into that
bart
okay that's one of the really questions
i have i'm just thinking about that
particular idiom of how to reach some of
these people that because i know a lot
of them like my my even my own siblings
are are support are the having it's a
long story but i have two siblings that
are
problematic in this area i gotcha all
right good well i appreciate the call
bart
thanks so much david love your show
thank you there's bart from california
advertising on fox news i mean what what
could it cost could it be 50 grand for a
spot it's probably not even i don't know
uh we should look into that
let's go next to
mark from memphis mark you're on the air
mark from memphis you're on the air
and mark from memphis last chance to
unmute and talk to me
oh boy i heard one i heard david
ah it's not going well there that's too
bad
um let's go to noah from fort lauderdale
noah what is how are things down there
the the craziness was just getting going
when i left miami about a month and a
half ago oh mr pakman you have no idea
it's crazy
i would almost go as far to say as
diluted
deluded or diluted
whichever works okay good either maybe
both yeah what's going on
um i uh i had a question about the um
so i was never really a political guy
until covid hit
and when covet hit i started essentially
studying
right-wing media because i knew the
circus was going to be great
um i'm curious to know about if you if
you have a connection or at least a
connection that i drew
about uh like right
agitation about kamala uh campaigning
for newsome
over trump campaigning for roy moore
so
if so is there an analogy between the
two yeah i uh i i think there is where a
lot of republicans would support roy
moore after all of the insane
allegations
but now there's
even more outrage
that kamala is campaigning for newsom
oh i see so you're you're saying is it
possible that kamala harris's supportive
newsome will hurt newsom
yes
i i mean it's really just it's an
empirical question
nationally kamala harris is not polling
very well
my guess is that in blue states she's
polling better and that in her home
state of california she's polling even
better
i
my guess is that the numbers have been
looked at by the newsom campaign and
they've made the call that it's it's
better for her to help but i understand
the concept if people don't like her
they might be turned off but here's the
thing
if you kind of like newsom but you don't
like kamala i don't think that her
campaigning makes you go vote for larry
elder you know so so i i'm not hugely
concerned about that
well my
my big concern is um
like i said i've essentially been
studying right wing media and
um
i'm sure you're familiar with candace
owens of course
um have you seen that she's put out a
statement essentially saying
that a national divorce is inevitable
you mean like uh like the country
splitting into two countries
yes oh i don't care what she says i
don't know that she's ever been right
about anything and she's one of the
biggest feminists i know so i i couldn't
care about what she says yeah
okay yeah uh
thank you mr pacman uh long time
listener first time caller uh got a lot
of respect for you in the show thank you
all right stay safe in florida it sounds
crazy down there
oh no promises all right very good
um
let's see who else we could chat with
today because there are so many people
that want to get on today
let's try um
let's go to greg peach greg peach you're
on the air
hi david
so i i'm actually i've been on in queue
for a while and you took a break um and
i was just really surprised because it
lasted like less than five seconds um
why did you need to take such a small
break i would think you'd need like at
least five to ten minutes for a
substantial break yeah no that's true i
i like to keep the brakes very short and
by the way are you running a lathe in
the background
oh you can actually okay shoot you got
me david my my audio's not perfect
i'm sorry
all right did you have a question today
um i i guess yeah i had a real question
have you ever considered uh like writing
books um like tom hartman he's written a
lot of books you know i have i'm
currently in discussion now uh about a
book and the question with the book is
what is the book about you know so i
want to make sure i'm doing something
like i don't want to just throw together
a book in a month like some people have
done and it's sort of like of no value
whatsoever
um but i do i am i am currently
exploring different ideas and treatments
for a book
okay sounds great thank you now are you
willing to tell me what is the power
tool that's running in the background
uh it's a it's an air filter i um
i just picked one up because i was
worried i'd get allergies i haven't had
problems with that and i just leave it
running all the time for like better air
quality okay do you feel that your
allergies are better with it on
yeah i i think it works good good all
right thank you so much for the call
yeah
all right well
uh sort of a
slow deceleration on the calls today but
i do appreciate everybody i was able to
speak to
and i look forward to speaking to more
people again
next time we take calls we'll go to a
break and be back right after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right let's get
right into your emails for the week if
you want to send something in comment
question trolling critique whatever um
use the email address info
davidpakman.com or click on the contact
button at davidpakman.com either way
it'll all go to the same place
let's go through and see what is on the
minds of the people that is ultimately
what matters
i heard from kay
who says hi david it's been interesting
seeing how many um for lack of a better
word crazies we have living us among
living among us in the us in australia
the only thing i want out of this when
things finally settle is an agreement
from the right that if you can argue
that no one can tell you what to do with
your body then at a minimum we should
all agree that no one can tell a
pregnant person whether or not they can
carry it they carry a pregnancy to term
i don't agree that a fetus is a person
but if we ignore that position
no one can argue against abortion that
you're taking a life
because your failure to take a vaccine
or wear a mask puts the rest of us fully
viable and already living people at risk
but i suspect consistency is something
right-wingers aren't really bound by
keep up the good work
appreciated you having guest hosts
rather than no show helps that i already
follow jesse and farren yeah i mean
listen k
without
saying this had this is the only way to
present the hypocrisy
the hypocrisy we are seeing from the
anti-choice uh right um with the my body
my choice stuff during the pandemic it
is an incredible hypocrisy and i i want
to remind people of something i've been
saying for a long time
their stated principles are not
sincerely held in many cases it's just
the talking point
that they believe
gets them to the political outcome they
want most readily and when the talking
point no longer works or doesn't apply
all of a sudden then they abandon it
completely they are
transparently dishonest in that way
let's continue next message is from matt
this is just horrifying matt wrote in
hi david my mom is a medical doctor in
north dakota
she told me today that she had a patient
who claims that a different medical
provider a nurse
told them that the covet 19 vaccine
causes an increase in quote non-food
cravings
for things like cigarettes alcohol etc
and literally in the nurse's notes for
that patient that my mom was reading
the nurse wrote down exactly that she
advised the patient against the vaccine
because the patient was trying to quit
smoking
obviously this is more anti-vax bs but
neither my mom nor i had heard of this
before i've heard of this one before so
i figured it might be interesting to let
you know thanks matt yeah you know
there's a sort of like the calls are
coming from inside the house type of
nuttery going on
and to hear that there are medical
providers that are opting against
getting vaccinated where it's allowed
that's extraordinarily distressing and
disturbing and then to hear something
like you know i don't think the vaccine
is right for you
because you want to quit smoking and the
vaccine will make you crave cigarettes
so that's a new reason
that they've come up with not to get
vaccinated horrifying stuff and as crazy
as any of these things sound to you or
me remember that there are people for
whom this sounds reasonable and that is
maybe the most horrifying part of it all
email from angie
angie wrote to me mr packman
of course spelling my last name wrong
very common that people who write in to
suggest conspiracy videos don't spell my
name correctly mr pacman
take a look at this youtube video i
believe that you will see things
differently this is a video
from
dr christina parks that's been floating
around
i don't even know if dr parks is a
medical doctor
you know this is another hypocrisy with
the right they love to play coy with
how does jill biden get to be called dr
biden if her doctorate is in education
um and then all of a sudden they have
people commenting on vaccines like that
person last week we highlighted who has
a phd in like organizational systems
commenting about fda approval process
anyway the christina parks video has
been floating around
it is not credible
it's been debunked
it is um
not something i would be paying
attention to let's just put it there and
i did see the video it does it does
makes it makes me see things differently
in that i'm realizing
there are people who are even more
gullible than i previously believed
that's what i learned from watching this
video and reading the comments next
email is from deanna
deanna wrote can you do a segment of how
many people got coveted at obama's
birthday
how many had coveted at the party and
made it a super spreader
just thought that it would be great for
those people to know the answer people
are asking me hey what about obama
as far as i know
the obama birthday
was not a super spreader event
uh i however
don't think there's anything special
about barack obama i said i went to a
birthday party a couple weeks ago 12
people went
vaccination was required and a test at
the door was required my friend got
tests and everybody was tested on the
way in
it felt safe it felt responsible when i
asked dr raccanello about it last week
he said you know even if someone was
incubating you probably have 24 hours of
not being contagious
assuming you got a negative test
um i don't know if everybody at obama's
birthday was tested we've not heard of
it as a super spreader event uh doesn't
mean there might not have been cringy
videos released that that's a totally
different story but i don't believe the
rules should be different for democrats
or republicans if you've been watching
this show long enough you would you
would certainly know that okay let's go
next to michael's email
this i find this one interesting michael
wrote to me about the voicemail segment
and michael said david i would first
like to say i enjoy the show i find your
temperament soothing on my drive home
from work you're funnier than people
give you credit for but if you let that
go to your head you will ruin it choose
wisely to the point sir i noticed you
seem to have stopped finding the humor
in these ludicrous voicemails you play
you look drained while they play if you
don't enjoy it don't do it gotta take
care of yourself first sir either way
love the content be well no i mean i
sort of play up
the the truth is michael this is
actually this is actually sadder
i'm kind of so desensitized by the
completely uh out of this world wacky
stuff that comes into the voicemail line
line in the email line
that i really
don't have nearly the reaction to it
that i should like i should be depressed
i should be drained by the voicemails
and emails that i'm getting from people
but for some reason i'm not and i think
it's that i've become desensitized so i
think i just kind of play up you know
when i'm listening to those voicemails
um but it's not about uh enjoying it or
not enjoying it or whatever the case may
be but let me tell you michael i really
do appreciate the concern that is a
really important thing i i love that
you're concerned about me but all is
fine if at some point i don't want to
play the voicemails it's as simple as
saying no more voicemails and i will
make the decision um because ultimately
i am the decider on the show okay last
one here we're including a hate mail i'm
including the full full name of this
person because it's not their real name
they write to me under a pseudonym john
smith
and this uh individual wrote to me and
said dude
you're a hack
biden left 85 billion military equipment
left behind including night vision
recognition technology which has all
afghans who helped american
30 uh i mean it's you know i'm reading
it with the grammar that it came in
13 additional u.s military casualties
this was the most one single event
f up by any american president in the
history of the world make that the
dumbest effing thing ever done by a
world leader in the history of the world
that was one sentence
continuing you support this
then you're an effing idiot you can only
hide ignorance for so long biden already
an idiot took the worst job an idiot can
take
now this idiot is on display for the
world to see i i'm having trouble
following who the idiots are
what a proud day for capital l liberals
maybe 85 billion was worth getting rid
of basically lib dems biden all members
of the squad thank you all will america
make it to the 2022 elections china iran
and russia
are getting ready to take the lead in
world power
so there's geopolitical confusion here
um iran is not in the running here to be
world superpower at this point in time
could be in the future but not not right
now
the question of joe biden leaving
afghanistan is one to which i have an
emphatic and definitive answer
we had no business being there and i'm
thrilled
that joe biden got us out the ark here
is george w bush got us in
we stayed for 20 years obama didn't get
us out
trump didn't get us out biden got us out
were there
uh tactical
elements
that could have been better handled yes
but there would have been tactical
elements that could have been better
handled if trump did it as well and when
trump was actually asked to articulate
with stuart varney last week on fox
business what exactly would have done
would you have done differently what do
you make of the specific criticisms
trump ranted about who knows what he had
no actual answer so i am very happy that
biden got us out 85 billion is very
little relative to what's been spent
uh and it is right for us to be out it
was you know the scrutiny that is being
applied to getting out over the last
month was never applied to 20 years in
afghanistan so you know john smith or
whoever
um
be mad at me if you want
but uh maybe spend a little more time on
syntax and grammar than making foreign
policy criticisms that you seem to not
fully understand all right my friend if
you have an email if you want to be
featured in the friday emails write to
info
davidpakman.com i look forward to
hearing from you but be polite be polite
guys don't be like john we've got a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at joinpacman.com get yourself instant
access plus when you're a member you're
supporting the show and that's a
beautiful thing we'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman